Let's imagine I wanted to send a message
to Cameron without anyone else being to
see that message.
If I were to just place this note on
Cameron's desk, anyone could come by and
read it.
I could find a box with a lock and
lock the message away but
then I have to somehow
get this key to Cameron.
That's not going to work because
anyone will be able to come by and
grab the key.
But what if Cameron already
had a box set up on his desk,
with his own lock, and the key to unlock
that box is always in Cameron's pocket?
He never shares that key with anyone.
I can then come by his desk, place
my message in the box, and lock it.
And no one else can
ever see that message.
In this example,
the box is called the public key.
The box can be left out in the open,
shared around without any consequence.
The key in Cameron's pocket
is called a private key.
Cameron never let's anybody else
borrow that key or see it.
This combination of public and
private keys allows me to securely
communicate with Cameron.
This same cryptography trick can be used
to authenticate a client with a server.
The server will send a random
message to the client.
The client will encrypt that
message with their private key, and
then send that encrypted
message back to the server.
The server will decrypt this
message with their public key and
if that value equals the same value they
sent, then everything checks out and
the client has authenticated.